the thing I want to look is it true the
thing in the film or will be allowed to
say this say the thing about how you can
spot the missionaries hello it's not
more crazy than that yeah I mean the the
fork maybe is a little general but
there's they have in certain kitchens
they have actually like mug shots like
all these photos of people that may who
they think are part of the Michelin
Guide so that they're constantly looking
at it's unbelievable the depth was they
don't it's really hard for them to know
they were still in mario batali was
saying he's like it still it's harder in
america but but in europe it's easier is
it the same guys what go all around you
about there there's like I don't know
there's like 40 or 50 of them or
something like that Wow yeah until the
thing I kind of made that number yeah it
was fair but putting the fork under the
table explain that to them well this
idea of that could put like a fork under
the table to see if anybody notices it
all these little things but they don't
drop the four no no the place it under
this and you don't notice them and see
if you to see you see if they'll notice
oh there's a missing Fork where is it
Wow but don't try that at Nando's I
imagine that we've all in those
Nando's bro you don't happen in America
you'd love it though you would like with
it yes it's like chicken a lot of
chicken bitter complaints and done
several well I like that that could be
on their poster Sienna Miller it's like
chicken
that's it right there essentially my
crazy crazy that's that's one nut no
that's - nothing's bent down like this
and I think you could hear the click you
know you just hear it you get used to
that clicking sound I thought oh yeah
these pants are really like they're oh I
think my ass is hanging out